alors soyez le ou la bienvenue aux
touristes la planète attrition tam-tam
canada c'est bien dit que donc un du
droit à l'eau magnol dans les jeunes
espagnols c'est ça alors alors on est
comme ça il ya deux espagnols ici il ya
la nôtre à nimy bel ami ou hé ben ami
qui est avec nous de la section
espagnole
paloma vous êtes maintenant cette
semaine avec l'association france à l
acam 1 vous êtes un peu comme domino
vous fait bouger très agréable de vous
retrouver à nouveau cette semaine
et puis on a aussi leonardo gimeno alors
bonjour oms de la section
latino-américaine qui est avec nous
parce qu'on a besoin de webmestres dans
ce laboratoire de diffusion absolue
c'est vrai il m'a tellement coupe qu'ils
n'ont mais on va s'appesantir sur la
question technique avant de plonger vers
notre sud actualité de la semaine si
vous le permettez vous avez apporté avec
vous black magic
oui c'est ça black magic c'est un don
personnel que effet international
exactement fait ils m'ont prêté ça c'est
pas moi c'est pas vous c'est une petite
boîte qui nous laisse rentrer des
caméras professionnelles à l'ordinateur
comme si c'était une caméra web c'est
tout mais c'est une trouvaille c'est
pour ça comme meilleure qualité d'image
en ce moment absolument
oui ça va mieux ça va mieux parce qu'on
est des plus beaux jeux wii ça descend
je pense que marie-claude vous allez à
poubelles encore que jamais marie-claude
notre voie du secteur français et puis
oui bout de la section chinoise est avec
nous également cette semaine alors notre
sujet on revient sur cette question de
ces demandeurs d'asile qui vient des
états unis qui fuit d'amérique d'un
autre homme qui arrive au québec autour
de 6000 le nombre semble diminuer ou
vous delà de l'importance là depuis
quelques jours c'est ce que rapportent
les médias mais pour beaucoup de
canadiens ont beaucoup de québécois
surtout on parle de crise ce à quoi se
refusent les autorités à politique en
place en parlant d'une situation
inhabituelle irrégulière mais il n'y a
pas de problème dans l'ensemble notre
question aujourd'hui c'est est ce qu'on
est prêt pour un débat sérieux sur
l'immigration au canada parce que cet
emprunt faire des vagues cette histoire
d'immigrants coup de personnes qui
arrivent des états unis qu'est ce qu'on
a appris deux boucles de nouveau cette
semaine à lyon n'aurait pas là mais on a
appris que on a appris que les québécois
en fait c'est pas tout à fait cette
semaine dans les dernières mal derniers
jours que les québécois sont un peu
inquiet de la situation de l'arrivée
d'aidés de six migrants des 6000 ans
demandeur d'asile
on a aussi appris que moi j'ai un petit
tableau ici pour vous dire qu'il faut se
poser la question c'est une crise ou non
en 2001 il y avait autour des 44 1000e
montré pendant que vous montrer ce
qu'elle nous vaut cette semaine on peut
montrer des vidéos des images de ces
réfugiés ou de ces demandeurs d'asile
qui arrive des états unis pour mettre
tous nos internautes dans le bain
d'accord exactement donc en 2001
stefania il y aurait eu à peu près 44
mille demandeurs d'asile en fait des
réfugiés accepté au canada
c'est en 2001 à 2010 est pour mettre les
choses un peu un perspective
on parle maintenant de 18 mille
demandeurs d'asile
donc on est encore dix sont dans la
marche qui a déjà été franchi a parlé
pas c'est donc aussi on veut appeler ça
une crise mais il faut se poser la
question il faut justement créé ce débat
mais
juste bon on est là dedans il faut se
pose cette pression là toujours sur ces
images qui ont été tournées par nos
collègues de la sib ici à radio-canada
donc on demande à widou qu'est ce que
vous avez appris de nouveau cette
semaine au sujet de ces demandeurs
d'asile qu'est ce qui vous a frappé
cette semaine c'est à dire que
l'attitude du gouvernement comment faire
changer au début si on se souvient de du
premier ministre trudeau son premier
tweet
ah on allait au les bras ouvert la porte
ouvert bienvenus soyez bienvenue chez
nous mais cette semaine on commence à
dire ben écoute on va commencer la fin
une enquête pour savoir ce que t'as rien
y ya pas d et mende et des gens sur noah
qui sont en train de faire quelques
complot pour pousser et on est en train
d au moins pour savoir est ce qu'il ya
des il ya des groupes de trafiquants
délinquants et on commence ce matin
justement ce matin par à l'arrêter dans
les nouvelles j'ai entendu dire qu on a
les bras ouverts mais on n'a pas la
porte ouverte je savais que ça veut dire
quand on essaie d'acheter une nuance si
on n'a pas si et quand on ferme la porte
au bon alors on est en opposition par
rapport à notre image
je pense ici marie claude et y sent bien
voir qu'on le premier ministre hugo qui
dit on est très ouverts et là on se fera
pas la réalité que quand on est trop
ouvert ça peut créer des remous 10 des
soucis moi ce que j'ai appris cette
semaine en fait c'est une phrase
simplement dans un article de notre
collègue les 20 secondes de la section
anglophone qui nous a rappelé un peu
comment nuit les canadiens avions fait
face à la crise après le tremblement de
terre en haïti et puis ce serait bon de
faire un effort de mémoire avant de
commencer pour pouvoir une bonne
perspective sur ce qui se passe en ce
moment parce que nous aussi nous avions
donné des 10 statues temporaire mais
seulement de 6 mois ou deux noms ensuite
ils ont été prolongées mais pas
indéfiniment
finalement ils sont plus du tout va les
lieux certains elle cecchini qui sont au
canada seulement qu' on constate une ado
qui ont été renvoyés alors c'est un peu
curieux qui ont une propre histoire avec
notre propre façon de gérer cette crise
oui et puis quel maintenant tout d'un
coup il faudrait faire fi un peu de ce
qu'on a fait nos mains avec cette
situation a pu accueillir à bras ouverts
sans poser de questions où sont comparés
des lycées qui ont eu une si je
comprenais aux états unis le statut
temporaire le site de sept ans beaucoup
plus généreux que les canadiens avaient
donné et puis on s'entend que c'est
leonardo on va revenir ici en studio
discuter ensemble préparé l'arrivée de
notre prochaine éviter ce sera donc une
vidéo sonore il ya beaucoup de gens qui
s'expriment ou dans cette affaire il ya
les modérés il ya les peureux il ya les
inquiète et il ya les radicaux et redit
coupe qui sont sortis de terre après ce
qui s'est passé aux états unis on est
beaucoup les médias ont été très
sensibles à leurs messages et eux mêmes
ont semblé en profiter telle une vague
comme des spécialistes du surfing
en quoi alors à l'eau sans jeux sur les
plateformes on a senti ça et on l'a
senti est dans la ville de québec où la
meute est l'un de ces groupes a dit qu a
pu manifester dans tout silence
ben oui tout cela silencieusement mais
avant la manifestation silencieuse ils
se sont quand même exprimé via leurs
médias non officiel sévèrement le port à
du canada les grands médias officiels
n'ont leurs propres médias c c'est la
réalité de l'internet aujourd'hui on a
capté pour vous un moment d'un discours
qui semble être le discours de beaucoup
de québécois modéré on écoute ça
mon nom est souvent brouillard je suis
porte parole la même sensation
d'aujourd'hui seco
protester quand gestion irresponsable
quand même un peu d'eau consommée
les gars sont inégales puis aussi un
pauvre souligner nos sports à l'inversé
parce qu'on a beaucoup de gens qui nous
parlent d'un périple qui donnant aux
situations qui n'ont aucun sens
puisqu'il y sont contraires à leur
serment
donc on veut juste leur faire savoir que
nous on sait que c'est pas leur décision
voilà un extrait vidéo puis ils vont
vous pouvez si vous voulez aller sur
notre site web via la suite bien sûr
nous on vous présente que le meilleur et
puis je vous demander vous avez donc
entendu ce discours il semblait pas
extrémiste se seconde qualifie d'
extrémistes dans ce sens mais est-ce que
c'était raisonnable les les craintes
exprimées par ces gens de là mult de la
mode je ne sais pas mais je crois que
c'est c'est valable le fait de se poser
des questions
le canada a toujours été une terre
d'accueil oui
cependant il faut bien gérer ça parce
qu'on sait déjà que souvent les gens qui
s'installent puis qui sont pas tous cas
pas une bonne gestion de leur arrivée
kempen bonne gestion de leur entrée dans
le milieu du travail ça peu difficile
pour une société c'est normal c'est
normal que se posent cette question là
donc indépendamment de ce que la meute
dit je pense que la société canadienne a
le droit de se poser cette question pile
est la question que vous vous posez
cette semaine est ce qu'on est prêt pour
faire une débat sérieux concernant
l'immigration et consommant le cas
particulier des demandeurs d'asile et
comble de ma base valable il faut la
faire céder balle et cana va être un
petit peu en retard par rapport à sale
angleterre a eu lieu a eu ce débat
oui nous sommes assez c'est une
c'est une histoire des basques à calais
réfléchi et les réfugiés
s'il ya eu l'arrivée il y avait un
discours qui dit c'est bella c'est c'est
vraiment étudié cas par cas les gens
étaient et investigués et
ils ont laissé une département des ddc
les nations unies qui fait cela il est
prévu la première évaluation car il ya
une deuxième évaluation de la partie du
grand nord canadien alors c'est normal
c'est le n'est pas mal de même c'est à
dire les gens qui viennent de cette
assume hippie qui passe par le chemin
brooks crâne c'est pas exactement le
même contexte la syrie c'est loin dans
ce cas il faut toujours faire les
missions une question de sécurité qui
s'est invitée et c'est sa seule massa en
fait est que je dis pas fermer les
portes
mais je dis est ce qu a fait un pitch
peu des recherches pour voir si c'est
vraiment les caps ici tout le monde est
apte pour rentrer c'est ce qu'on fait
avec tout le demandeur d'asile
d'ailleurs c'est pas c'est pas nouveau
pour les syriens sont pas nouveaux pour
les haïtiens c'est ce qu'on fait pour
chacun des personnes qui rentrent au
pays
quand j'ai fait les démarches pour
revenir au canada je fais une permis de
l'interpol c7 c'est une des spas affaire
pourrait devoir faire l'application ces
gens qui arrivent des états unis on y on
ne sélectionne pas là il rentre et puis
là il faut le flou fous de savoir qui
ils sont ce qu'ils disaient c'est que
les syriens et bien eu un triage fait
par les nations unies au préalable et
ensuite le canada faisait sa propre
enquête là il faut tout faire faut
partir de zéro
quelques études à ce niveau-là m'en
venir à ce débat qui ne doit pas avoir
lieu au canada sur les migrants
je vous le montrer dès que sera présente
au canada l'immigration parce que c'est
une valeur du pays
un isolement une valeur du premier
ministre justin trudeau sont si on ne
s'est pas levé il ya un an et demi on
est ouvert on était ouvert à 20 mais
regardez vidéo numéro 3 qui nous
montrent que nous sommes pas le pays le
plus ouvert au mans mais presque le pays
le plus ouvert au monde c'est au prorata
de la population c'est-à-dire
pourcentage de personnes qui sont des
migrants ou d'origine extérieure
c'est en australie qu'on ne trouve 26%
ce que c'est ça que deal de l'homme j'ai
pas j'ai pas des longues-vues mois pour
voir ça et puis au canada c'est combien
juste le deuxième ça veut dire quoi ça
présentement si vous allez au canada en
moyens nous avait une chance sur combien
de rencontrer quelqu'un qui est né à
l'étranger ou 5
[Musique]
ce qui m'amène à la question remue
ménage donc retour ici en studio c'est
une question je l'appelle maintenant
comme sa question remue ménage
donc c'est à la fois une question jeu
une question pour savoir si vous êtes
intelligent vous le cacher bien
alors voici il y atteint 2,6 millions de
citoyens en ce moment au canada
combien y at-il de citoyens au canada
dans 100 ans en 2000 117 sait on voyage
beaucoup d'entrain dans cette émission
si demain matin on fermait notre
frontière aux immigrants donc plus
d'immigrants plus personne pour nous
aider à accroître notre population dans
100 ans 36 millions de citoyens
aujourd'hui combien il y en aurait-il
local 6,26 millions 1,6 million baissent
donc de 10 millions venir
oui qui dit mieux jésus autour de trente
30 millions ce qui aurait 30 millions
moins de canadiens
non non il rêve vous n'êtes pas loin de
la bonne réponse votre côté mais ricco a
eu une estimation à la maladie moi je
dis 26 7 h 30
moi je veux dire
24 24 20 milliards au moins bête - c'est
pas de price is right ici n'a pas la
bonne réponse rapide à gagner quelque
chose si je gagne c'est parfait cadart
écoutez on va voir la réponse moi c'est
pas moi qui l'a donné c'est un
journaliste qui est un jaunissement des
pandas qui a publié un article c'était
au moins de juin
il s'appelle nile chihab et il a écrit
un article ce à quoi ressemblait le
canada sans les immigrants je vous
propose de l'écouter
nous sommes prêts pour la vidéo numéro
quatre un sympathique jeune homme je
viens danser une invitation pour
participer à skype cette semaine elle a
dit non j'ai quelque chose d'autre à
faire alors jouer c'est de sa faute
nous voici quand même le canada aurait
perdu le tiers de sa population
le vieillissement de la population et le
nombre de défaites qui augmente dans
notre société est plus important que le
nombre de naissances
on n'a pas suffisamment d'enfants au
canada et finalement après quelques
décennies on n'est plus capable on
serait plus capable de renouveler notre
population
en revanche après un siècle avec un
scénario avec l'immigration et une
migration qui ressemble à celle des
dernières années c'est environ huit
immigrants pour 1000 canadiens se sont
rendu compte qu'avec l'immigration on
ferait plus que doubler la population du
canada
donc d'un côté avec l'immigration une
migration semblable aux dernières années
on doublerait la population du canada et
de l'autre côté sans une migration on
perdrait le tiers de notre population
après cent ans le poids démographique du
québec
selon les projections même avec
l'immigration en ce moment il
diminuerait parce que le québec est une
province moins diversifiés que que la
moyenne canadienne
on accueille un petit peu moins
d'immigrants on a aussi des citoyens
québécois qui quittent la province pour
aller vivre ailleurs au canada
alors tout ça fait en sorte que la
population du québec augmente un peu
moins vite par rapport au reste du
canada
mais ce qui m'a frappé aussi c'était le
poil
ristic des francophones au canada selon
des simulations aux environs de 2030 la
population non immigrantes francophones
va arrêter de se renouveler et va
commencer à décliner ce qui veut dire
que en fait pour assurer un poids
démographique linguistique du français
au canada
eh bien il faut reposer ça peut vraiment
sûr sur l'immigration et c'est ce qu'on
voit au québec déjà en ce moment deux
immigrants sur trois parle français au
québec utilisent le français et sans eux
en fait le poids démographique des
francophones s'effondrerait même
aujourd'hui allons ainsi il ya parmi les
dix provinces canadiennes celle qui doit
compter le plus sur l'immigration pour
sauver lalinde la fierté francophone
c'est le québec qui par certains côtés
la ville de québec notamment et plus
réfractaires à l'arrivée de nouveaux
immigrants le sait de paris chez free
vient de l'otan parler parce que mon la
ville de québec c'est un problème alors
sur ces images maintenant je vais vous
montrer à quoi ressemblerait parce que
il a parlé beaucoup
voici une image qui en a qui vont me dit
me mo je vous jure c'est une seule image
alors voici c'est un diagramme qui
montre à quoi ressemblerait la
population au cours des dernières années
ce avec ou sans immigrants on voit que
il ya une année charnière indexé à
orange
oui c'est orange là où l'orangé le bleu
se sont joints en 1990 pas le diplôme ou
encore une fois 1987 autour de la sas
moment là que l'immigration est devenue
déterminante pour le canada pour assurer
l'augmentation de la population et le
diagramme nous montre que plus ça va
plus avoir augmenté rapidement cette
importance de la de l'arrivée de
nouvelles personnes pour faire croître
l'économie
maintenant il ya quelque chose que je
voulais vous demander
je me suis juste pour vérifier combien
de québécois c'est une question pas une
question humaine âge mais si vous avez
entendu dans les médias beaucoup de
sondages depuis quelques temps d'hier
les québécois sont pour son compte
pour vous me donnez une statistique vous
souvenez vous vraiment d'une statistique
de sondage réalisé par exemple par radio
canada sur la perception des québécois
par rapport à l'immigration pour ou
contre
je me souviens que c'est environ 5 1% de
la population québécoise qui est
craintive à l'arrivée de nouveaux de
nouvelles personnes de nouveaux
immigrants au pays incluant les
demandeurs d'asile d'enseignants pour ça
c'est un bon chiffre s'est 51%
on va arrêter de poser des questions 51%
qui veulent empêcher les réfugiés
d'entrer directement la frontière et au
moins 39 % des personnes interrogées
croient que l'arrivée récente est
important de migrants va rendre le
québec - sécuritaires ont rejoint le
point de vue que vous éprouvez vous
essayer de décrire un peu plus tôt qui
est une donnée importante ces bonnes
seulement qu'on a peur parce qu'on voit
ça va nous coûter de l'argent pour ça
c'est que bon c'est parce qu'on a besoin
des immigrés oui on continue à face à la
promotion de l'imitation mais dans ce
cas là il faut vraiment faire toute
l'époque y en a fait tout les migrants
qui ont établi qu'une auxi mais ce matin
j'entendais paul journée de la presse
dire qu'on n'a pas vraiment besoin de
six migrants au niveau économique que
leur poids économique n'est pas si et
les six grands est si important si on
leur donne pas d'emploi c'est sur
exactement doxa d'ameublement de type
d'immigration du type d'emploi que ces
personnes peuvent avoir en arrivant ici
aussi s'il continue d'aider de faire des
bébés ou non et de la qualité de leur
emploi donc avec moi j'appelle ça des
affaires d'intégration plus saine plus
peuvent contribuer de manière égale aux
citoyens et plus les soins peuvent leur
demande une contribution rial s'ils
parlent la langue cette importance c'est
tragique va vous montrer ces photos qui
viennent de calgary tournées par nos
amis de la sib ici sont très actifs dans
des stations un peu partout à travers le
pays où est alors voici ça s'éteint un
centre sportif de calgary l'hiver
dernier une équipe qui a été filmé ces
images parce que vous voyez des jeunes
qui arrivent un peu partout dans le
monde
les nouveaux arrivants et on les initie
on veut cesser leur montrer c'est quoi
le canada au hacker de sa ville ça donne
des scènes un peu ce réel ou déjà mettre
des patins pour la première fois pour
toucher la glace pour la première fois
lui on se demande donc est ce qui va se
passer
savez-vous bien pendant des conseils on
a enlevé le sont pas ça se passe en
anglais c'est comment c'est passionnant
et ça m'amène à vous demander c'est quoi
le sport national des canadiens
est ce que c'est encore le hockey nous
ce serait pas autre chose paloma on vous
pose pas la question vous l as douanes
il y en a deux un pour les versions
pauvreté la crosse c'est pour l'été puis
léo qui voulait les rendre comme les
officiels mais pour l'hiver et vous
connaissez beaucoup de gens qui jouent à
la crosse vous non bah oui je connais
des personnes comme le castor c'est très
symbolique mais j'ai l'impression que
même en été la crise est encore
nationale étant donné qu'il ya beaucoup
de discussions qui continuent on choisit
les membres d'equipe puis tout ça en
fait c'est une erreur au niveau du
nombre il ya plus de jeunes blancs qui
jouent au soccer
pardon c'est la nouvelle réalité c'est
dans les grandes villes toronto
c'est ça vraiment qui fait pencher la
balance et montréal maintenant qui suit
ou une nommée l'histoire ce qui est
quand je suis arrivé ça fait quinze ans
on voyait les enfants jouer au hockey
dans la rue maintenant à l'été
maintenant on les voit et c'est vraiment
un jour au foot au football
les migrants n'ont été donnés la faute
que les frais de son lait frais pour
avoir des enfants contre des immigrants
mais c'est long mais c'est vrai succès
ce délai d'inscription qui sont très
chers pour les une équipe je sais pas
exactement mais prenez un kit double ead
est ok ça coûte à peu près 2000 2500 $
des 60 cents sur le show mais habité en
afrique et c'était ça ou alors pas avant
des chinoiseries dont je voulais vous
parler de ça parce que j'ai une
statistique qui va vous renversez nous
elle est renversant parce que bon frein
trop malhotra main alors 1900 1867 on se
reporte baltes 1 c'est l'année de la
création canada est né ce moment là cent
cinquante ans au 1er juillet dernier
donc depuis ce temps là entre ces deux
dates 1867 et 2017
combien d'ennemis de millions
d'immigrants le canada at il accepté en
son sein combien de millions c'est pas
important dire partager
je veux faire
on s'assoit sur les épaules je tienne
getis 2011 tous milieux oui ok 2 million
le million
mais sauf que tu es millions sans
compter les roses en face qu'aujourd'hui
il ya un canadien sur cinq est déjà né à
l'étranger donc 1036 millions 250 mille
par année oui
donc on a travaillé d'accord de
militants pillon marie féminine 20
millions 12.55 de ses mérites l'on sait
rester calmes et 17 millions les plus
proches de la bonne réponse ensuite
c'est leonardo ainsi je ne parle pas des
zones non en 2036 on continue le jeu là
qui dit mieux
de quitte ou double en 2036 un canadien
sur combien sera un immigrant ou un
enfant des migrants on dirait que sur
365 fois sur cinq
tous sont 11 4 7
un sur deux la moitié des enfants
d'immigrés c'est quelque chose ici en
studio elle a combien qui sont immigrées
ou enfants de migrants
c'est la police et 3,5 mais c'est vous
parier dès 2013
c'est ça ce sera en 2005 56 3 sur 5
d'accord alors on est prêt maintenant
pour le finir le débat en studio avec un
brin de débat très sérieux sur est-ce
qu'on doit d'en avoir un débat sur
l'immigration au canada mais tant qu'on
a bien ri allons vers le le terrible
commentaires que voici
jeudi terry mais vous connaissez je
jouerai sourire en coin
voici quelqu'un qui est jugé modéré et
qui semble dire qu'on ne peut pas avoir
de débat sérieux en ce moment en réponse
à notre question cette semaine parce que
il ya une récupération des politiciens
il ya du politically correct parce que
vous faisiez allusion la seule la
semaine dernière un peu pas mal
c'est ce que vous disiez savez vous qu
est ce qui fait tenir et ouf on peut
faire rejouer la bande vidéo on a tous
qu'est ce que vous disiez la semaine
dernière qu'on peut pas parler sans être
critiqué
c'est exister de même posé des questions
[Musique]
mais moi je rajoute c'est qu'il faut
quand même à la base pas avoir en
entrant dans une discussion pas avoir un
sentiment de supériorité rapport aux
autres parce que des si on se fie aux
gens qui tablaient sur la vidéo de 20
oui des gens que tu peux nous sommes en
discussion avec ces gens là parce qu' un
parti sérieux problèmes au niveau suisse
au problème c'est pas est ce que c'est
possible ou pas possible c'est qu'il le
faut absolument c'était important pour
la société
si vous dites que la moitié se serait en
immigrant oui enfants d'immigrants c'est
vraiment ça va c'est vraiment là pour
l'arrêter c'est vraiment quelque chose
de super important on écoute et ensuite
on vraiment d'accord
alors des chiffres quand même assez
éloquent qui nous disent que la question
de l'immigration c'est toujours explosif
et que quand c'est sensible à ce point
là c'est tout-à-fait instrumentalisable
dans les france bazzo chroniqueuse et
femmes des médias au québec croit que
l'heure est au débat et non à une autre
opération de balayage sous le tapis dans
les politiciens qui sont les
l'immigration qui continue à casser le
québec en deux ce serait vraiment du jeu
via l'isthme de l'aveuglément que deux
lignes et une question qui a été
beaucoup instrumentalisée au québec et
au canada dernièrement or pendant ce
temps là il ya plein de vraies questions
qui se posent mais qui sont envoyées
vraiment sous tapis
comment intégrer les nouveaux arrivants
et par le marché du travail comment
franciser les immigrants pourquoi
vouloir les franciser la question des
seuils d'immigration qui se pose partout
en occident je vois pas pourquoi on ne
peut pas poser cette question de ici ne
serait ce que pour réfléchir calmement à
ça la question de la répartition
territoriale des immigrants au québec
la question des réfugiés comment
d'oeuvre est il arrivé il ya toute cette
question de procédure officielle vers ce
qui arrive illégalement à la frontière
ça pose tous des questions dans tatie
qu'on n'a pas toujours face aux réfugiés
des questions d'éthique par rapport à
ceux qui font leur demande dans les
règles bref beaucoup de question c'est
quelles sont les migrations dans un
monde où la mondialisation et on voit
bien ce que dira c'est raté ou les murs
pullulent un peu partout ce sont des
questions essentielles et au québec on
veut on tend à balayer ces questions
pourtant légitime
non c'est pas du racisme c'est la
xénophobie c'est même parfois de
l'humanisme que de se poser c'est
qu'elles sont là bref on temps allait
balayer sous le tapis
alors voilà au tout début de cette
émission
stéphane c'est valable de se poser cette
question là parce que dans la société il
faut toujours se poser des questions
attendait là où la technique le battage
de deux secondes avant qu'ils aient la
vidéo fini c'est qu'amélie la petite
caméra qui est loch et pointer l'écran
est lâché c'est pas black magic ça donc
il faut remplacer les batteries conti
budget spécial une chose que j'ai
beaucoup aimé de son commentaire sur la
question concernant la francisation et
puis cette semaine ça a été à l'ordre
à l'ordre du jour parce qu'il ya eu la
diffusion sur les ondes est ici erdei à
radio canada dans le cadre des grands
reportages
un documentaire qui s'appelait les
québécois de la loi 101
il faut rappeler en hausse auditeurs que
la loi 101 c'est la loi qui oblige à
loos immigrants apprendre l'éducation à
faire le saut du casque leur éducation
en français les enfants d'immigrants
particulièrement donc c'est une loi qui
a permis d d'assurer le français que les
français font partie de la population de
la vie quotidienne au québec
depuis quarante ans maintenant donc que
dans ses reportages là dans ce
documentaire les jeunes québécois
d'origines diverses dit c'est que ils
sont inquiets du fait qu'ils se sentent
pas partie de la population québécoise
parce que souvent ils se font poser la
question d'où viens tu
ils sont la plupart d'entre eux n'est
ici au québec
donc où beaucoup d'entre eux donc il
faut se poser la question pourquoi on se
fait toujours pour cette question ça
fait qu'on après combien d'années on est
on fait partie d'une société
donc ça ça ça c'est tout cette question
là il faut vraiment pas le laisser sans
suspens exactement sa réponse il faut
discuter bon il faut crever l'abcès
je pense que vous avez aidé beaucoup à
la procédure chirurgicale aujourd'hui on
conclut il faut conclure parce que c'est
commencer le l'internet et agriculteurs
mais le commentaire de marie france
moi j'étais enfant ce qu'elle dit je
suis d'accord avec ça c'est qu'elle ou
il faut il faut un débat il faut un
débat encadré avec des gens qui vont
vraiment pouvoir toujours remettre pas
que sa dérive pour que tu y ait toujours
des faibles et des rappels historiques
pour que vraiment on perd pas la
supporter pour parler anglais delhumeau
verte à la radio ça parce qu'elle est
déjà l'un des boss citoyens sur les
médias sociaux qui disent ce qu'ils
rapportent n'importe quoi de
l'information par s'est partiellement
comprise donc il faut vraiment un débat
encadrés par des experts des gens qui
ont entendu d'aussi beau c'est un débat
découverte de tous nos quartiers un
débat frein par un débat politique c'est
à dire que il commence pas les
intéresser à essayer de prendre
l'immigration comme un point pour ou
contre leur politique c'est ça que
j'aime pas une chance de donner un point
de vue là je vais t'emmener là dessus
oui on parle beaucoup de l'immigration
parce qu'on veut on dit c'est bon pour
l'économie
ça fait croire économie s'il n'y a pas
augmentation de population économie ne
croîtrait pas peut être même dans les
pays où il n'ya pas de l'immigration dit
faut que l'accueil la population croit
parce que sinon on va sur dépassé par
les autres pays où la population des
plus importantes on a un modèle
économique basé sur la croissance de la
population qui me semble un peu fou
parce que arrivée à 15 milliards de
personnes autour de la terre ça va
éclater quelque part
donc il faudrait peut-être réapprendre à
prendre qu'un tout nouveau modèle je
veux pas partir de révolution mais un
débat mais je pense qu il ya quelqu un
procès parce qu'on se comprenne
oui oui et vous me fait penser au japon
c'était moi je fais pas se rappeler ce
que vous venez de dire que c'est à dire
la population c'est diminue mais comme
je pensais pas un pays qui ouvre sa
porte aux à l'immigration
pas du tout mais c'est à dire vrai ils
doivent trouver un moyen de se
débrouiller peut-être sais c'est
intéressant tu te faire une recherche
quelque part pour savoir comment aux
autrees gst promis légère décroissance
mais nous sommes un petit peu mieux il
arrive maintenant avant une croissance
malgré le fait la population diminue
donc cesser ses piques il vit le plus
rapidement présentement un monde faut
pas oublier non plus que pendant tous
ces débats y des gens qui dorment dans
des tentes en ce moment cela une harde
ici des centaines fait que la compassion
comme disait madame bazou faux-pas faut
toujours regarder des chèques et des
noms si ça c'est pas juste un problème
économique c'est un problème humanitaire
dont il faut se pose est que cette
question avant toute chose c'est ça
qu'on doit voir très bien merci avait
beaucoup aidé ici chacun s'épie la
semaine prochaine on va parler de la
surpopulation canadiens possible sur des
sujets aussi j'en ai un autre c'est les
potins d'elle et les potins concernant
nos artistes canadiens qui ne pense qu'à
faire beauty
on va commencer avec céline dion les
socios si non c'est la semaine prochaine
mais l'émirat semaine prochaine
si vous avez vu venir la semaine
prochaine oui c'est là
bravo alors merci beaucoup à joe
martinez oui ou non on vous retrouve
dans trois semaines
marie-claude aussi ma à la semaine
prochaine
leonardo générale jb non merci pour tous
aujourd'hui
merci à vous